hey one quick note Madison cawthorne
thankfully as one of the most radical
members of Congress to be elected in
2020 was defeated in a Republican
primary good he'll be leaving on January
whatever the date is 2023 when the new
Congress is inaugurated except it
appears that he has already left there's
a very interesting report from The
Citizen Times uh Madison cawthorne
vacates offices before end of term
constituents calls go unanswered he has
stopped working Madison cawthorne is no
longer working he's still an elected
official he's still a member of Congress
he isn't working anymore and this is
just really instructive about what
happens when you vote for these people
none of these people want to work this
is the exact same story as what we saw
with Donald Trump during the campaign
over the summer in 2020 Trump by many
reports had essentially stopped all
presidential duties he wasn't receiving
the presidential Daily Briefing even
when he was receiving it he wasn't
really paying attention but he wasn't
even ostensibly receiving it
um and then in the period between the
November 2020 election and when Trump
ultimately left the White House he
wasn't doing any work these people don't
actually want to work they don't want to
work Madison cawthorne has just left he
has abandoned the job that quite frankly
he was never actually interested in
doing it was sort of like it was sort of
like college right he thought this
sounds kind of cool but he didn't
actually want to do the stuff that's
required people around him were a little
bit creeped out he did a terrible job
messed up a bunch of stuff and then
ended up kind of going back home to live
with his family they're not really
sending their best and this is just
another example where again I would say
to you to Republicans are you so
committed to the party
that you would quite literally rather a
guy who goes home instead of doing the
job than a Democrat who cares and I know
the answer for many of them the answer
is yes
it's it's quite it's that simple and for
many of them especially the ones who say
our elected officials shouldn't even be
doing that much it's extra exciting to
see a guy go I'm not going to do
anything I'm just going home because
they don't want government doing stuff
so as insane as this is
you will find Defenders of Madison
cawthorne who will say I think it's good
he doesn't need to be there voting on
all sorts of stuff that government
shouldn't even be involved in he has
abandoned his job we'll have all of the
clips from all of these segments on our
Instagram which you can find at David
packman show we're going to take the
shortest of breaks and then the show
continues